So that basically starts us wanting to
rethink some of the ideas that we've had
about lenses and defocus things.
Let me review some of that just to kind
of get us started, because then we
actually going to look at how we're
going to change these things.
Of course, remember that basically what
we have and we have a lens like this.
We have an aperture, the opening, right?
The opening is the amount of area that
actually goes though the aperture and
it hits the sensor after
the shutter is open.
The shutter is the one that controls
the amount of time, the aperture,
the amount of light that enters.
Now, if you recall some of the simple
optic stuff we looked at this before.
There's also always a sensor,
a lens and the light of course,
from the focal plane goes through.
And it's for
the object on the focal plane,
what basically happens is the image
is formed on the camera sensor and
that's exactly we get a focused image.
And of course,
the image of the point light source,
if there is a point light source at this
point here where the object is we will
basically get Something like this.
And of course, the point spread function
would just be a short line like this.
So, of course, this is inverted.
The white bright one basically shows
this is my point spread function here
for this feature.
This is the optics we have looked
at many times in this class.
Now let's actually start thinking about
what defocus does in the context of this
simple lens system,
which basically means now is I'm
going to move the object
at a different distance.
So the same light source from here would
now basically mean that the actual
convergence of this light is
happening a little bit ahead.
This is where my camera sensor.
So, of course,
it's now getting to be a little bit,
forming a little bit a er,
before this location.
And of course,
there's now divergence showing up,
which then results in a point spread
function that's much thicker.
And of course, that translates into
the image of the defocused point light
source would look something like this,
much wider as show here.
Let's move the object further back.
Of course, when we do this,
you can notice that the point
spread function gets wider.
And of course, we also know that would
mean that the image of the defocused
point light source would look bigger.
Just to kind of continue this exercise,
we will actually now do last one,
where we basically move this further
away and you know, this is even wider.
And of course,
bigger blob is showing up here and
it's a defocused point light source,
which is point here.
So we know about this kind of stuff and
with that, gives us a little bit of
an idea about how all of this works,
something we looked at before.
Another further example of
this is it gets bigger.
And here now, I'm showing you last
stage where I move the object further.
And of course, the point spec
function is really wide and
the defocus point light
source is also much larger